Fear of terrorism is widespread in
America.
Many Americans have actually changed how
they live their daily lives.
A significant number of Americans say
they avoided sporting events,
concerts,
and other public events because of their
fear of terrorism.
Let me ask you a question.
What are people most afraid of?
You may think it's insects or natural
disasters or even public speaking,
but an extensive survey conducted by
Chapman University in Twenty 15 said the
biggest fears and Americans are cited as
the quote manmade disasters.
These fears include bio warfare,
terrorism,
and nuclear attacks.
Forty four percent of Americans are
afraid or very afraid of terrorist
attacks.
Compare that to 28 percent for public
speaking and 25 percent for insects.
Fear of terrorism actually peaked
following nine slash 11,
as the majority of Americans will
worried that they or someone they knew
would be a victim of a terrorist attack.
I want to suggest that what the public
fears is mirrored in Hollywood cinema,
especially the Zombie movies directly
following nine slash 11.
But to start,
we have to go back in time to the horror
movies of the 19 fifties.
So let me rephrase the first question.
What were people most afraid of?
Insane.
Nineteen 51.
We all know the atomic bomb is very
dangerous that may be used against us.
We must get ready for it.
With the Korean War,
Soviet nuclear testing and mccarthyism
in full force.
In 1950 polls showed an astounding 68
percent of Americans thought the Soviet
Union would use an atomic weapon against
the United States.
This fear was even used later as a scare
tactic in an infamous campaign ad by
Lyndon Johnson showing just how powerful
the fear was on the pump.
What are the stakes?
And all of God's children are to go into
the dark.
We must either love each other
are we must die.
So how did horror movies reflect this
fear?
The 19 fifties brought on a wave of
disaster movies were aliens are monsters
attack like war of the worlds,
the Blob,
and the thing from another world.
When you watch battle scenes from the
original war of the worlds or attack of
the 50 foot woman or Godzilla,
you notice the parallels between these
horror movies and the destructive nature
of the atomic bomb.
In fact,
the director of Godzilla was very blunt
about his intentions with the now iconic
monster.
He said,
quote,
the theme of the film from the beginning
was the tear of the bond.
Mankind had created the bottom and now
nature was going to take revenge on
mankind for Americans.
However,
the fear was channeled towards the
Soviet Union,
our biggest global threat at the time,
in the same way that Godzilla stomps on
buildings and is immune to bullets,
so to win an atomic bomb,
wipe out cities and be entirely
unstoppable by us.
Maybe it's no coincidence that the
Japanese film Godzilla was such a huge
success in America.
The Japanese fear of the bomb was just
as relevant to Americans at the time.
Now,
let's jump to the 21st century.
We're no longer threatened by a huge
visible global superpower.
Actually,
the fear of terrorism is quite the
opposite.
It's nothing like Godzilla.
A giant monster who drops in on a city,
a terrorist hides in the shadows,
disguise themselves as an everyday
citizen and causes society to collapse
from the inside out.
So here's my point.
It doesn't.
The method of destruction for a
terrorist sound a like the method of
destruction for Izombie.
First,
it's important to note the explosion of
the Zombie Genre.
Io Nine posted a nice graph showing a
boom in Zombie movies in the early two
thousands paralleling with mainstream
video games like resident evil and call
of duty and spilling into other media
like the TV show,
the walking dead.
There's no doubt that zombies have
infected the public conscience.
Twenty eight days later is one of the
first successful Zombie movies to come
out following nine slash 11,
and it highlights contemporary fears of
terrorism and decay of social order.
The scene that most strongly ties the
movie to terrorist fears is actually the
very first scene.
The deadly virus is created in a lab by
making chimpanzees watch footage of
Arabic mobs,
fighting police,
burning cars and beating each other up.
This virus is literally created from
Arabic violence.
I particularly like this shot,
which makes the human look like it's
regressing back into a terrifying
animal.
An important element of the Zombie genre
is that the enemy comes inside a
community and spreads from person to
person.
This sounds eerily similar to the method
of attack for a terrorist.
Sleeper cell hides within our board was
ready to strike and once we can finally
spot it,
it's too late to stop.
I think another key difference between
fifties,
monster movies and Zombie movies is the
role of the government.
In monster movies,
the government often fights against the
enemy,
but in 28 days later,
the government hasn't
abandoned them.
There's no government horses to go home
and there's always a government during a
bunker or plane.
There's no government police.
Not only that,
but in the movie,
the soldiers actually fight against the
protagonist.
In the 21st century with the
controversial invasion of Iraq and
government surveillance,
terrorism has brought on a distrust of
our own government where the 19 fifties
government was always joining in the
fight against a common enemy.
It appears that during a Zombie
apocalypse,
we shouldn't count on any government to
protect us.
What's so special about cinema is that
it's such a democratic art form when it
comes to art forms like painting,
music or creative writing.
The message is only channeled through
one person,
but with cinema,
the final work is the product of dozens
of people.
Not only that,
but a production process as expensive as
making a movie requires that mainstream
movies appeal to as many people as
possible.
As a result,
movies tend to be a window into the
general mindset of the society it was
made in.
This means that the subject matter of
the successful horror movie has in its
subtext,
a reflection of the general fears of the
environment it was made in.
There are things that regardless of time
period and society,
humans are scared of.
The dark is a universal fear because we
can't identify the threat.
So a movie like don't breed seems to do
well because like jaws and the ending of
silence of the lambs,
it's scary when the threat can see you,
but you can't see that it's a timeless
fear.
But what about fears that do change over
time?
I talked about monster movies versus
Zombie movies,
but I also think mainstream horror
movies about religion or another perfect
example,
religion is at an all time low in the
United States.
More importantly,
the fear of damnation is low,
meaning that religious groups tend to
spend less time on the pain and torment
of hell in their teachings and more time
on the love and forgiveness that comes
from salvation.
This idea is especially true in the
Catholic Church who revised their
catechism in 1994 to remove the literary
fire and description of hell in favor of
a metaphorical place,
symbolizing the loss of one's faith.
So how is this idea shown in modern
movies around 40 or so years ago?
Most movies about the supernatural
centered around religion.
The devil is often the center villain.
In successful movies like Rosemary's
baby,
the omen and the exorcist nowadays,
those supernatural beings are still
present,
but religion is largely ignored.
The ghost is a former mental patient or
some unexplained being.
The exorcist is about a child being
possessed by the devil or Finn has a
very similar premise,
a child who is acting strangely,
but religion is hardly even mentioned.
The fact is that people don't find the
devil as scary as they used to,
partly due to less religion and partly
due to a conscious choice to focus less
on damnation in religious doctrine.
There's no doubt that there are
detectable trends in what horror movies
choose to find scary.
If you want to know what people are
afraid of,
you could run an expensive and time
consuming statistical study,
or you could just look at what horror
movies they find scary,
so the next time someone says,
don't be scared,
it's just a movie.
Don't believe them.
Thanks for watching.
Slightly full break from the norm.
Just a little slot in the need of all
back home.